est ce qu'il ne serait pas temps de vous
proposer une nouvelle trilogie de vidéos
sur l'univers de game of thrones avec
les brome estreux thibault et hershey
fonds a décidé de renouveler
l'expérience qui vous avez énormément
plu et donc vous re proposer trois
vidéos dédiées à l'univers de game of
thrones et où chacun apparaîtra dans la
vidéo des autres chez le maître thibault
vous retrouverez le fameux complot des
maistre lié à la série de house of the
dragon's chez ce bon vieux héros cf jack
n hagard le véritable gagnant de game of
thrones est chez moi nous allons tenter
de comprendre ce qu'il se passe pour
aria après la saison 8 de goat nous
avions fait la dernière fois john snow
et j'estime qu'il y a quand même pas mal
de choses à dire pour aria devenue une
sans visage est carrément la tueuse du
roi de la nuit ariano propose une fin
très ouverte concernant son personnage
elle souhaite découvrir ce qu'il y a à
l'ouest de westeros là où les cartes des
hommes s'arrêtent et bien écoutez je
vous propose d'analyser et de spéculer
ensemble autour de ce sujet que devient
arya stark à la fin de la saison 8
[Musique]
mais avant de commencer la vidéo
remettons un peu de contexte
probablement le personnage préféré de
beaucoup de fans et à juste titre arya
stark est l'une des protagonistes qui va
nous proposer un des parcours les plus
intéressants de la série arias ne
correspond pas aux codes instauré par
west héros ce qu'elle aime c'est l'
aventure le combat et souhaite être
maîtresse de son propre destin et non
devoir dépendre d'un potentiel mari ou
autres seigneurs à qui elles seraient
fiancés et jusqu'au bout malgré les
épreuves arias aura toujours la même
ligne de conduite qui sera même renforcé
par son désir de vengeance et son
apprentissage en tant que son visage ce
qui a réellement changé chez arias et
qu'elle a aujourd'hui l'assurance qui
lui manquait et le pouvoir de réaliser
ses souhaits la preuve en est avec le
roi de la nuit l'unicité des riads et
montre qu'elle était la digne
protagonistes à mettre fin à la longue
nuit et ce depuis la saison 3 avec la
prophétie de mélissandre une unicité qui
traduit le décalage qu'elle a avec ses
frères et soeurs la obra naissance à
sont devenus des dirigeants arias
souhaitent quitter le pays et découvrir
ce qui n'a encore jamais été découvert
délaissant le confort et la royauté et
c'est la thématique du jour arias est la
protagoniste qui nous offre la fin la
plus ouverte et son désir d' aventure va
l'amener à devenir une exploratrice
comme heroes f voyons donc de quoi il
pourrait advenir tout d'abord il faut
intégrer que comme tout le monde ou
univers fictif il existe une base qui
permet sa création une base d'où
viennent toutes les inspirations et
évidemment bas c'est le monde réel donc
pour mieux appréhender l'avenir daria
après la saison 8 les références sont
une première porte de sortie comme l'a
expliqué j aar martin l'auteur de
l'oeuvre est le concepteur de tout ce
qui entoure game of thrones l'univers
est basée en quelque sorte sur l'époque
médiévale européenne que ce soit en
terme d'histoire avec notamment le
conflit stark et lannister inspiré par
le conflit york et lancaster une guerre
civile anglaise apparu juste après la
guerre de cent ans pour l'exemple mais
également en terme de géographie et
c'est là le plus intéressant puisque le
continent de westeros serait une sorte
d' angleterre grossi à la taille de
l'amérique du sud avec comme pour
l'europe à sa droite le continent des
sauces qui symbolise l'asie et plus en
dessous sauteriaux ce basé sur l'afrique
donc on ne va pas se mentir si nous
restons logique au vu de sur quoi
l'univers est basé arias qui souhaite
aller à l'ouest de l'europe donc à
l'ouest de westeros arias serait associé
à christophe colomb et découvrir est un
analogue de l'amérique surtout que là où
l'univers de goat est bien conçu c'est
que nous sommes basés sur la vision des
personnages et nous évoluons en même
temps que nous ne savons rien sur ce
qu'il y a à l'ouest de westeros tout
simplement car personne n'en est jamais
revenu personne n'a jamais pu faire le
récit de ce qu'il ya à l'ouest cependant
là où l'idée cariat serait associé à
christophe colomb qui découvriraient
l'équivalent de l'amérique dans goat il
existe une alternative encore plus
intéressante et qui appuie également
l'idée de cette découverte la force de
game of thrones et sa capacité à
reproduire l'histoire réelle à sa
manière avec derrière tout cela des
symboliques fortes qui appuient la
cohérence et la légitimité de son
univers c'est pourquoi arias pourrait
découvrir l'analogue de l'amérique non
pas en tant que christophe colomb mais
plutôt en tant que vikings effectivement
la maison stark puise énormément dans
les mythes nordiques déjà tout
simplement l'inspiration du ragnarök un
grand hiver qui envahit la terre et où
les dieux et les géants de glace qui
franchissent le bifrost vont s'affronter
nous retrouvons forcément l'idée des
humains contre les marcheurs blanc qui
ont franchi le mur pendant la longue
nuit mais plus particulièrement nous
retrouvons des symboles forts comme le
loup ou encore les corbeaux qui sont des
emblèmes de la maison stark et qui sont
des familiers dodin lui même d'ailleurs
tous les enfants stark tir d inspiration
dodin par rapport à leur lot ou bran
avec les corneilles sans oublier
forcément tout ce côté peuples du nord
provenant du groenland un des pays dont
le climat est l'un des plus froids de la
planète tout comme les stars qu'avec le
nord bref arias représenterait donc les
vikings à la découverte de l'amérique
néanmoins il faut savoir rester dans le
doute effectivement si la logique nous
amène sur cette piste n'oublions pas que
martin ou même les show runner
concernant la série restent les maîtres
il est tout à fait possible qu'il n'y
ait rien ou que ce soit quelque chose de
différent de l'amérique mais bon je vous
avoue que refaire partir arias dans une
nouvelle aventure vers l'inconnu pour au
final lui faire découvrir d'art rien du
tout je trouve ça quand même un peu
bizarre voire presque idiot bref tout ça
pour dire cariat symbolise clairement
les premiers grands explorateurs elle
est vouée à découvrir de grandes choses
à la fin de game of thrones
néanmoins il y a des choses à dire
puisque l'avenir daria peut être
également inspiré de personnages
provenant des livres et aussi s'appuyer
sur la venue prochaine de la série house
of the dragon en 2022 en effet arias est
très souvent associé à l'exploratrice
elissa farm ans peut-être que ce nom
vous dit quelque chose ami fidèle des
targaryen à une période située il ya
plus de 250 ans par rapport à kempton
elissa souhaite se faire financer un
bateau par la maison des dragons sauf
qu'elle va subir un refus lui donnant
l'idée de s'enfuir loin en volant 3e de
dragon et li sava se servir de ses yeux
pour financer son propre bateau à bravo
le fameux sound chez isr un navire avec
lequel elle va tenter de traverser la
seine 7,6 pour découvrir ce qu'il y à
l'ouest de west et rose de par ses
traits de caractère et ses objectifs et
l'isaf armand ressemble beaucoup à arya
stark
c'est une femme forte et intrépide qui a
soif d'aventuré par delà les mers comme
découvrir ce qu'il y à l'ouest du mont 2
par exemple
c'est possiblement une grande source
d'inspiration pour le personnage daria
et son avenir car si elle est canon à la
série cela sous-entend cariat marcherait
sur ses traces ou bien si elle est sa
représentation elle reproduirait donc
son histoire et son parcours à la
découverte de l'ouest et c'est à ce
moment là qu'un lien avec la série house
of the dragon peut se faire un lien qui
va permettre de trouver des réponses et
de consolider l'univers de la série
corliss vela riom était un navigateur de
légende à l'époque de la danse des
dragons soit environ plus de cent
soixante dix ans avant la série game of
thrones il est le marin qui a marqué
l'histoire maritime de l'univers grâce à
ses nombreuses expéditions aux quatre
coins du monde là où c'est intéressant
c'est kelly ça n'est jamais revenu de
son périple à l'ouest et c'est justement
corps lisse qui va retrouver son bateau
le thunder en piteux état dans le port
de la cité d'achat y ville la plus à
l'est des sauces comme si elle avait
possiblement fait le tour du monde et vu
que corliss vela riom est un personnage
central du récit de house of the dragon
ce dernier va nous permettre de
possiblement mettre en lumière cette
fameuse légende elissa at elle
véritablement existé pour la série ou
bien est ce que arya stark en et sa
représentation indirecte mais il existe
un autre point intéressant dont je
souhaitais vous parler et c'est encore
une fois un possible lien avec par hans
stark
étant la corneille à trois yeux branne
et la mémoire de l'humanité par le biais
de son pouvoir appelé green sight ce
dernier peut avoir des visions que ce
soit en temps réel du passé ou même du
futur maintenant désigné comme le roi de
westeros il ya de fortes chances que
bran souhaite consolider l'histoire du
monde et en apprendre davantage plus
rien n'empêche aujourd'hui nous avons
l'exemple de la recherche de drogue ont
qui a disparu et que brown souhaitent
retrouver ou bien si la théorie que je
vous proposais comme quoi la mission de
john n'était pas terminé et bien cela
pourrait être le cas pour aria également
grâce à aria sans désir de découvrir ce
qu'il y à l'ouest de westeros bran avec
son omniscience va pouvoir se servir
d'elle pour justement découvrir aussi le
reste du monde inconnu des sommes déjà
la maison stark ne possède plus
réellement de flotte depuis très
longtemps notamment par rapport à une
très vieille histoire liée à brandon
stark le cas renner et le bateau que
dirige arias et est identifié avec le
symbole de la maison ce qui signifie que
quelqu'un a financé ce projet voire
encouragé arias à le faire évidemment
arrière est une princesse du nord il y a
donc des chances qu'elle se soit financé
son bateau elle même grâce à ça et
winterfell mais il existe aussi une
possibilité que bradley et aider dans
cette tâche en tant que roi de westeros
notamment par rapport à l'équipage daria
mais surtout avec la découverte d'une
nouvelle culture arias pourrait faire de
grandes découvertes sur des savoirs
magique qui pourrait rendre bran encore
plus puissants par exemple nous savons
que bran grâce aux arbres coeur sculpté
par les enfants de la forêt peut avoir
des visions encore plus précise du passé
présent et futur et ce malgré les
distances on ne sait pas ce qu'il y a or
des continents déjà connu mais imaginez
qu'il existe d'autres peuples avec des
vestiges permettant à bram de se
connecter d'ailleurs lors de l'épopée
des lices à l'un de ses navires a réussi
à revenir et il était fait mention d'un
kraken qui a détruit un des bateaux de
la flotte étant donné qu'il existe déjà
des créatures magiques dans game of
thrones comme les dragons un kraken
intéresserait forcément branne imaginez
si ce dernier grâce à sa capacité de
change pour réussissait à le contrôler
il pourrait protéger son royaume via la
terre grâce à drogba et via la mer grâce
aux kraken
tout ça pour dire carrière va permettre
à branne d'alimenter encore plus ses
pouvoirs puis grâce à ses potentiels
découverte étant la soeur de la
corneille à trois yeux bran serait comme
une bonne étoile protégeons de loin
arias et la guidant vers la réussite
puisque effectivement de par la présence
d'un équipage donc 2 ares 1 qui ont une
potentielle famille et même arias il est
évident qu'elle aimerait revenir
raconter ses découvertes et bien bran
pourrait assurer également le voyage
retour et au passage grâce aux
découvertes daria cette dernière
pourrait fonder une nouvelle maison
stark basé sur des richesses de l'ouest
comme des fruits des nouveaux animaux
etc c'est d'ailleurs comme ça que
corliss a fait partie de l'une des
maisons les plus puissantes de west eros
et il y a de fortes chances car y'a
marche dans ces mêmes traces
enfin voila je trouvais ça intéressant
de traiter du cas daria poste game of
thrones et c'est maintenant chose faite
évidemment même si l'on se base beaucoup
sur l'univers qu'instaure les livres la
fin daria reste propre à chacun et c'est
exactement ce que souhaitaient les show
runner avec la fin de la saison 8
concernant beaucoup de personnages
l'essai de l'ouverture pour pourquoi pas
de potentiel suite il y avait beaucoup
d'acteurs de la série qui aurait bien
aimé voir ce que arias va découvrir à
l'ouest et peut-être qu'un jour nous
aurons une série dédiée à ça mais voilà
dans tous les cas ils voulaient terminer
sur quelque chose d'ouvert arias est
probablement l'un des personnages les
plus uniques de la série et le fait que
ce soit elle qui nous propose la fin la
plus ouverte possible notamment comparé
à ses frères et soeurs et bien cela
colle vraiment bien avec ce qu'elle
représente j'espère en tout cas que la
vidéo vous aura plu si c'est le cas
n'hésitez pas à me le faire savoir avec
un commentaire un petit pouce bleus et
puis ben n'hésitez pas à vous abonner à
la chaîne pour ne louper aucune vidéo
est checké un stade g et twitter etc si
vous n'êtes toujours pas rassasié en
termes de contenu game of thrones je
vous invite à découvrir les deux vidéos
que mes deux confrères ont concocté et
où je vais apparaître dedans également
le complot des mèches reliées à house of
the dragon chez m e thibault et jack and
as garé le véritable gagnant de game of
thrones chez l'explorateur heroes c'est
ce que le 'lion' rares sont avec vous
égouttez c'était targo rock merci à tous
allez ciao tout le monde
[Musique]